H
REVEALS ABOUPLE WH BE WORKING T
BEWE>> D.
>> Reporter: CNNISG A O
HE MICN PRIMARY LAST MONTH.
>> S
CO>> Reporter: IT IS EXTRA
TRAININORS
BUT INCLUDING THE ACTUAL PAI
IN VOTERS, HAND OUEVEN HELP INN
IS ALARMING.
THERE'S AUFNG IN THIS
UPCOMING ELECTION, SE
GOING TOE
ON A SWIVEL AND JUST START
S IRREGULARITIES>> Reporter: TH.
>> IEY WERY THEITRAINERS THEY CE
AND MAYBE HI SMALL PEN.
YOE NOTES.
>> IF WERE OBSERVED WITH A PEN
AND A PIECE OF PAPER WRITING ON
T'S WHY YOU'VE GOT T
IT SRE
AND IT'S NOT JUST WHAT'S BEING
TAUG IS DOING THE TEACHING.
E T OF THEY
BUSINESS THAT'S HAPPEN
HAPP AGGTI
>> THAT IS ELECTIOERPATRIC WHIN
WROTA BOOK CAL"TAND HAS A BLOG
ABOUT VOTING MACHINEEADISINFOUT
KNOWINGLY SO IN OUR CRACY,LIAMSF
>>EA WIDECTED INTERNE
G MACHINES
O  T
BUT HES ASKINGL WORKK. LITTLE O
TOO IS SEE
ETHER OR NOT THESE MACHINES
NNECTED TO THE INTERNET.>> RepoK
TO CNN, BUT THOTHEADER
YOU ARE TRAINING THTO BE UNDER.
AT'SHE WORDS YOU WERE USING.
G WHY.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, IF YOU E
YEAR WERANY
PROBLEMS>> Reporte
STFIWI
BALLOTS.BUT SHE'S AN ELECTION D
SHE FILED A BASELESS LN
IN 2020.N LEGING ECTD
>>O F REFRAME IT AND
MAKE IT MORE FUN AND
INTERESTING, I SAID, JUST, YOU
KNOF CAUSING A BS AND THINGS LI
T DOWN
JUST KIND OF BE LIKE S
T , YOU , LET ME KW
AT'S GOING ON.
orter: WHILE MICN'
PRIMT
SMOOTHLY -- OTHING WRONG-  ERT
DETROIT'S G CENTER
FOATEDLY GETTING
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN MICHIGAN
SS THEIO
UAKE SURE THE U-ME
S FROM POLL L E
CAES FOR SECRETARY OF RN GENERA.
KALEIDA MITCHELL SWING
STATES.
ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'SETESGOINHING THE BA
TC VOTING, WING  KNOWING WS ON
PLANNED CHAOS.
E
RADICALIZED.
>> Repor T MHI
PARTY.HEY THINK
DEMOCRACOM T CL CIALISTS, WHERE
AR PREPARECH AITH IELREW GRIFN .
ON W
ELECTION?
>> TARE TRYING TO GEED.
ATTORSA
CLERKS ARERED AND
REMOVE SOME OF THESE PEO
VIOLATING
ANDERSON, THE KS E ELECTIONE
GA ALLY ARRN F THE VOTING
SYSTEM.AND WHEN THEY ACTUALLY GS
MANY TIMHE P
GOOD POLL WORKERS.
ANLSO,YOREPORTN A LOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SPREADING THESE
FRHI O
AT GUY HAD HE'S
O
THEORIES.
THB YOU G STUFF.
>> THIS A COMPLETE
TH
I'M TELLING YOU THIS GOE
UR MIKKNOW,
THE MY PILLOW GUW WE D FEATURED
AFTER SEMINAR VOTE DENIAL THINGS
THUGH.
IT HAS TUR